Emme peas have questioned commissioners
designate stella kiriakidis Didier
renders Helena dally and Sylvie gula on
health justice equality and the internal
market protection of patients rights
beating cancer and a holistic approach
to health care are the goals of stella
kiriakidis as health commissioner
kyriaki this comes from Cyprus where
she's an MP and was previously a
clinical psychologist the Committee on
Environment public health and food
safety questioned her on the effects of
pesticides digitalization of health
systems and access to medicine I know
firsthand the importance of
well-functioning health systems and that
collective health of our societies
depends on the individual health of
every single citizen
Didier Enders is the nominee for justice
Commissioner the law graduates served in
the Belgian government for 20 years in
posts including defense Foreign Affairs
and deputy prime minister he was
questioned by the Committee on civil
liberties justice and Home Affairs and
the Committee on legal affairs Emmie
Pease asked him about human rights and
holding multinationals to account they
also pressed him on possible sanctions
against Hungary and Poland and how to
ensure Member States respect the rule of
law trust me I will not hesitate to act
whenever the rule of law is in danger
I will no compromise when democracy is
at stake
Helena Dahle from Malta has been
proposed as Commissioner designate for
equality she has experience working for
women's and minorities rights as
minister in her home country the
Committee on women's rights and gender
equality and the Committee on employment
and Social Affairs Twister on
reproductive rights gender identity
equal pay and child care equality is not
a zero-sum game
the empowerment of women and persons
coming from minority backgrounds is of
benefit to all
sylvie cooler is the nominee internal
market commissioner the deputy director
of the Bank of France has served as an
MEP and Minister in the French
government she was questioned by members
of the committee's on internal markets
and consumer protection and on industry
research and energies along with the
Committee on legal affairs MEP questions
focused on her suitability given an
ongoing judicial inquiry as well as on
her plans for the digital economy rules
on competition and protectionist
measures in certain EU countries
prosperity model sushi on deep-ando not
way capacity Romania beyond atolls
showed courage in a Transformers show
numeric the vote in parliament to decide
if the Commission as a whole is accepted
or rejected is scheduled for the 23rd of
October